you know you're not the one traveling to
come down here to to sacrifice all I'm
sacrificing
me all that from now I can say first of
all first of all let me tell you
something I can say whatever I want to
say because I'm a grown-ass woman yes
Kim oh okay where do I start Kim and
Usman break up she actually broke up
with him I'm done here
after an argument that started because
he wanted her to clean up the hotel room
but then Kim ended up revealing all of
these hurtful comments that Usman has
been saying to her the way I walk is
wrong the way I dress is wrong is that
why am I here seriously I don't do that
to you there's a lot I like about you
but I don't say it he commented on the
way the lady walks
it was just little things like talking
about my weight they're talking about
how I'm gonna need a tummy tuck wow
honestly I'm proud of Kim after hearing
all of that she stood up for herself in
a way that I've never seen her stand up
before every time I say something it's
like Tit for Tat oh well you do this
well I sacrifice this for you oh we well
I'm doing a favor by being with you I
don't want to be no man's favor she did
let out a good cry though
a long good cry
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia I hope
you are feeling the holiday cheer
Santa's coming to town
oh my God and if you're not trust me I
understand there's a lot going on in the
world right now but what I'm reminding
myself is that what you give energy to
grows so if you find yourself feeling
down in the dumps maybe think about
where you've been placing majority of
your attention and try to immerse
yourself in things that feel more
positive and joyful
hopefully you'll see a difference before
we get into Kim and usman's long overdue
breakup guess what y'all Michael cheated
on Angela yes and she has proof when I
got back from Nigeria me and Michael was
on a good note we were
happy when we left it was back to normal
like two weeks we've been on the phone
every night every 24 7 like we used to
do the spark was there the love was
still there I felt like we were on the
way to you know getting ready to bring
him here and be husband and wife Angela
says one of her friends don't know who
sent her screenshots of Michael texting
another woman cheating on me and at
first I was like okay that could have
been fabricated Angela always thinks
he's cheating but then Angela says she
also received a voice note that Michael
sent to this Mystery Woman This Girl is
31 and they met on his Instagram and the
moment she started playing it I said oh
Michael is really out here creeping
whispering and everything take a listen
I got him right here
not the kiss through the phone do you
believe you said that to this girl
that's how you talk to me
like he he wrote my heart like he really
blew my arm
he really broke my heart I didn't
deserve this
oh I don't condone cheating at all but
if someone was constantly talking to me
like this
money [ __ ] I would be looking for love
somewhere else too you know I called
Michael immediately and he's telling me
it wasn't like that you know he's trying
to tell me that he was lonely but he
didn't mean nothing he said but because
he realized he does love me and he was
just a play thing
fish
one minute I want to blame myself I'm
confused I'm so confused
why do you want to blame yourself the
obvious because I can be a [ __ ] but
this is why I didn't want this to
remember people think I'm controlling
they weren't controlling I knew he can't
handle this I knew I personally don't
think you can stop someone from cheating
on you if that's what they want to do
they're going to find a way to do it
Angela tried so hard to keep Michael
from cheating on her and it ended up
happening anyway what's that quote for
us control freaks Elizabeth Gilbert says
quote you are afraid to surrender
because you don't want to lose control
but you never had control all you had
was anxiety Angela's anxiety caused her
to fly all the way to Nigeria and it
still happened there's no right answer
right now well she says she doesn't know
if she's gonna let Michael go which
probably means she's not she can't get
over the fact that she still loves him I
don't know what to do no
[Music]
all right let's move on to Kim and Usman
can I take him on him the kid's very
slow okay this one yes you want to go
and listen to me come on look he wants
to go too Jamal is so over it at the
beginning of the episode things start
off on a good no between Usman and Kim
they enjoy a day out with Jamal usman's
brother Muhammad his wife and little
mahadi at an amusement park and Kim and
Usman find themselves playing Mommy and
Daddy with mahati
you like it
yeah although mahadi's dad was all
smiles taking pictures at first it seems
as if this moment turned out to be a bit
uncomfortable for him I mean it was
uncomfortable for me as a beware cute
but uncomfortable okay
thank you guys for coming out oh that
baby was ready for that spoon
they all sit down to discuss the
adoption process once again and mahadi's
parents tell Kim and Usman that they
still haven't come to a decision
mahadi's mom straight up says she is not
feeling it is
and when it happened today it wouldn't
happen next week it'll be a couple years
you know and I just
what a couple years well at least yeah
foreign
immediately you get money like a month
or so I want to see like
how I can bring him close to me all the
time the parents even tell you yes
yes trying to rush this process is a bit
weird and sketchy and what he says later
to Kim makes it even worse but we'll get
to that it appears to be the next day
and Jamal is leaving his mom behind in
Nigeria to head back to the States
relax don't see you in a few days yeah
give my cats a kiss for me okay okay
it's a Mexican food for me all right
you know hugging me
all right nice to meet you bro take care
I will okay I will see y'all
all right peace out love you love you
too bye love you
love yourself
you asked me to say that
after using and Kim say bye to Jamal
they seem to be in good spirits but the
next day Everything Changes yeah I'm
sorry the way I walk is wrong the way I
dress is wrong it's like why am I here
seriously I don't do that to you there's
a lot I like about you but I don't say
it you make me feel so incompetent
sometimes I don't like that
I'm sorry
doesn't mean anything if you're just
gonna do it again Kim and Usman get into
it after he started quote nagging her to
clean up their hotel room and that kind
of escalated and then it was just little
things like talking about my weight
they're talking about how I'm gonna need
a tummy tuck I don't know if it was
stress I don't know if it was tension I
think the adoption thing was in this Kim
let's not blame it on the stress or
adoption okay by now we know that Usman
has shown a pattern of taking shots at
your self-esteem I said I'm very sorry I
I was doing that and I was I was
laughing but it doesn't sound like
you're playing and then everything oh
yeah I don't pick up the room right I
don't dress right my stomach's too big I
mean why are you even with me the
question now Kim is why are you still
with him after all of that if someone
acknowledges more of what's wrong with
you than what's right I wouldn't even
want to be their friend let alone their
fiance Kim mentioned before that she
received the same type of treatment from
her ex-husband which is interesting
personally when patterns like that show
up in my life where I've experienced an
issue with someone before and I keep
experiencing it again and again with new
people I don't take the blame for their
behavior but I do step back and ask
myself is there a part of me deep down
that feels as if this is a treatment
that I deserve is there a part of me
that feels as if I'm Unworthy of
receiving better because I'm learning
relationships are here at the end of the
day to help us grow as individuals and
they tend to mirror back to us ways that
we can learn to love and accept
ourselves more I have to do all this to
conform to you what the [ __ ] are you
doing for me seriously
oh yeah
we have to bring some levity into this
okay I'm sitting here thinking about
adopting a baby but you can't even hold
a conversation with me we don't even
have sex
tired of feeling like I'm not enough to
leave his ass you know you're not the
one traveling to come down here to to
sacrifice all I'm sacrificing stop
giving me that as an excuse please
because at this point I'm asking you for
I'm telling you I'm just telling you
cannot come here and start telling me
all that from now I can say first of all
first of all let me tell you something I
can say whatever I want to say because
I'm a grown-ass woman so don't ever tell
me I can't say
Kim said uh-uh honey don't you ever
I am here for it this is great good job
Kim put your foot down don't allow
somebody to make you feel bad about
yourself I would like to respect I don't
think I'm asking for too much
UL Smith thinks he's surprised and Kim
is a lucky winner that's what it is Kim
takes a seat next to him and they
attempt to talk it out I'm thinking
about adopting a child with you you're
not adopting I'm actually adopted yeah
but it's still changing my life
then on the side note of that huge
sacrifice for me too dude I'm not just
you guys don't do it then no you're not
don't know don't breathe then oh my God
that's not what I'm saying she thinks
like she sacrificed a lot I think I
sacrificed the mosques you can't give me
challenge I'm even thinking of adopted
because of you and you are telling me
that you do a lot for me it can't keep
on going this way
if I get this voice
I'm going to be happy with that is it
just me or does it seem as if Usman is
using his nephew's Life as a pawn
you know I'll be honest sometimes I
wonder if I take Kim's side too much and
if I'm not being fair and balanced when
it comes to Usman
but
think about his behavior not even
something I know what it is his behavior
rubs me the wrong way I know that there
are two sides to every story but
does anyone get his side does anyone see
it anyone
let me know in the comments I was just
thinking of all the ways that I'm gonna
have to change my life for this at home
you always feel like you do things can
barely me being with you is something
that nobody I cannot nobody will do it
because you're with me
Kim gets ticked off when Usman chooses
to get on his phone during the middle of
their conversation you know what you're
you are
I'm done
Kim goes on to say if they can't even
have an adult conversation how are they
going to raise a baby ding ding my
thoughts exactly I'm done here
[Music]
Kim gives Usman the ring back and walks
out
she is working away all the time the
letter should come back and say sorry
I am done
things that I care about is that who is
that person that can give me peace and I
think we'll never have peace
it sounds like Usman wants someone who
will let him do and say whatever he
pleases
Kim comes back to the room which is not
a huge surprise so
I don't want to end it with you I don't
want to not marry you oh Kim like
sometimes you I feel like you make me
feel like like I'm just not good enough
you know
I want you to want to be with me I don't
want to be anybody's favor
I thought you were with me because you
let me right
[Music]
levity you always think or you feel like
you're doing a lot
and you say you sacrifice the most I
never said I never said that I never
don't put words in my mouth
for you
he's taking his nephew away from his
mother and father to make a woman that
he's been with for a year and a half
happy
make it make sense if I have my idea I
don't need to have another wife I would
just be with you and then I'll sacrifice
the whole joy that you are enjoying but
I shouldn't enjoy Usman starts the guilt
trip Kim and then he takes it to another
level this is the ring
you remove it you keep it here and you
say you are done
so I think it is high time or just go
back home and look for somebody who is
around my culture my you know like
everything is the same and just find one
get money and continue with my life like
that
and then I I pray for you if you get the
best a man that is going to be better
and better and better than me I'll pray
I'll help you with prayer for that amen
yes seriously okay all right
hold it together Kim hold it together
Kim ends up storming out again and this
time Usman also grabs his things and
actually leaves a hotel I cannot be in a
relationship that is so toxic and it
look unhealthy to me
I don't see any reason why a woman that
is 18 years older than me will be
behaving like in somebody who is like
younger than me
Kim tries her best to keep it together
I've been through a lot and I can't just
sit here and just like let some June
just sit there and just like tear me
down and that's how it feels to me but
eventually she had to let out one of
those gut-wrenching cries I texted him
and then he said you will never get the
respect I give you by any man but since
you broke up with me you'll find out
soon thank you I said it's not like you
really care anyways you made that clear
now it's turned to this
[Music]
hey she'll be all right it's just a
moment in time and it's time
to Let It Go all right next week is
Christmas so there will not be a new 90
Day Fiance episode but the following
week New Year's Day the first episode of
the four-part tell-all is airing and
this four-part tell-all has a new twist
and it looks juicy for the very first
time we'll follow our couples inside
you're you're a crybaby kiss my ass dude
shut up you shut up and outside the
studio stop I don't even know what's
going on here you know this woman she's
my wife the way you expect me I want you
to please it's better just please and
please let that be a capital no I think
Houston Loki played the out of my mom
every time I say anything y'all just sit
up there and talk about how much I'm
defending them you're damn right I'm
gonna defend him it's not gonna be a
good stupid ass
get up shut up don't get your teeth
fixed doesn't it look good
okay y'all don't be mad at me but I will
not have a recap for the first part of
the tell-all because the studio is
shutting down for the holidays I know I
know but I will be back to recap the
second part of the tell-all and the
third and fourth and of course if there
was something that happened in part one
of the tell-all then I need to catch you
up on
I'll definitely do that when I get back
also over the holidays we are dropping a
special edition of 90 day replay where I
take a look back at the biggest moments
that went down in 2022 be on the lookout
for that that should be out shortly
all right 90 day fans fam happy holidays
and happy New Year I'll see you next
time
[Music]